Joe said he really had no choice even though he made a decision that most of us would be horrified to make ourselves. Here's what happened. He was in prison. He had served eight years on a robbery conviction. And he got accused of killing another prisoner, which in many states can get you the death penalty. He was innocent. This was later proven definitively. But his lawyer wasn't very good.
乔说他真的别无选择，尽管他做了一个我们大多数人自己做起来都会感到恐惧的决定。事情是这样的。他当时在监狱里，因抢劫罪已经服刑八年。后来他被指控杀害了另一名囚犯，在许多州，这可能会让他被判处死刑。他是无辜的，这一点后来得到了确凿的证明。但他的律师不太称职。
When I first met him, I asked him have you ever represented anyone before in a capital murder. And he told some, I'm  going to be honest with you. He said, I represented seven people so far. He said six of them got the death penalty and one had received life and 50 years without the possibility of parole.
我第一次见他时，问他以前是否代理过死刑谋杀案。他很坦诚地告诉我，他说，到目前为止我代理过七个人。他说其中六个人被判了死刑，一个人被判了终身监禁外加50年，且不得假释。
The actual details of Joe's trial are not my concern here today. The fact that a guard witnessed the crime and named the real killer on the stand but was ignored. The fact that all the witnesses against Joe were prisoners whose testimony radically contradicted each other's. All you need to know is that justice wasn't done. The jury found him guilty, which brought Joe to make a decision that he never told his lawyer about.
乔审判的具体细节不是我今天关心的重点。事实是，一名狱警在现场目击了犯罪过程，并在证人席上指认了真正的凶手，但被无视了。事实是，所有针对乔的证人都是囚犯，他们的证词彼此严重矛盾。你只需要知道，正义没有得到伸张。陪审团判定他有罪，这促使乔做出了一个从未告诉过他律师的决定。
When it came time for sentencing, which was the next thing that would happen in this case, the penalty phase where they had to determine the sentence now that he's been found guilty. The jury was going to have to rule if Joe would get the death penalty or get life in prison.
到了量刑阶段，也就是本案接下来要进行的部分，他们必须在判定他有罪后决定刑罚。陪审团将不得不裁定乔是会被判死刑还是终身监禁。
Those were my two choices. And I went back to the prison telling myself that I only had one option. And the only option I had was to make sure I received the death sentence. And I came to the conclusion that night just between and the guys that was in what they call the unit with me. We all talked about it. And they all came to the same thing I said, which was there was too many guys in prison who had life and 50 years without parole. Or life without parole. Who might be innocent or whatever but they are stuck in prison because they don't have a lawyer and they can't get anybody's attention.
这就是我的两个选择。我回到监狱，告诉自己我只有一个选择。我唯一的选择就是确保自己被判死刑。那天晚上我得出了结论，就在我和跟我关在同一个牢房的人之间。我们都讨论过这件事。他们得出的结论和我一样，那就是监狱里有太多人被判了终身监禁外加50年不得假释，或者终身监禁不得假释。他们可能是无辜的或者怎么样，但他们被困在监狱里，因为他们没有律师，也无法引起任何人的注意。
So I figured if I end up getting life in prison without the possibility of parole, I'm stuck. Any legal work that we did on my case, I've had to do it myself. Or any publicity I'm going to get, where am I going to get it from? I don't have a death sentence. So what if a guy got life and 50 years? We hear about them every day.
所以我心想，如果我最终被判终身监禁且不得假释，我就被困住了。我案件的任何法律工作都必须我自己来做。或者我能得到的任何公众关注，我从哪里获得呢？我没有被判死刑。所以如果一个人被判了终身监禁加50年又怎样？我们每天都能听到关于他们的消息。
So when the penalty phase came and he put me on that witness stand, I had made my mind up that I'm going to think of every bad act I've ever done as far back as I can remember. Every bad act my sisters, and brothers, my father, my mother, my neighbors. Everything bad I could think to tell them. Everything bad I could think that I could tell them I did while I was in prison, I told it. Because I wanted to make sure I received the death sentence. Because I figured if I received the death sentence, I'll have a lawyer. And I might be able to get some publicity. And I might be able to overturn this wrong conviction I have.
所以当量刑阶段到来，他把我带上证人席时，我已经下定决心，要想到我记得的最坏的事情。我姐妹、兄弟、父亲、母亲、邻居做的每一件坏事。我能想到的告诉他们的每一件坏事。我能想到的我在监狱里做的每一件坏事，我都说了。因为我想确保我被判处死刑。因为我想，如果我被判死刑，我就会有律师。我或许能得到一些公众关注。我也许能推翻这个错误的判决。
And if you read my penalty phase transcript, you'll see in there that I went out my way of making sure I received that death sentence.
如果你读过我的量刑阶段笔录，你就会看到，我竭尽全力确保自己被判死刑。
I actually have a transcript of your testimony right here. And it's really amazing what you say when you're on the stand. Like you say that you're not against the death penalty. You say, here we go, I'm just going to quote directly.
我这里正好有你的证词记录。你在证人席上说的话真的很令人惊叹。比如你说你不反对死刑。你说，我们要开始了，我直接引用你的话。
You say, "I'm not speaking to keep from getting the death penalty. I still have certain beliefs. I still believe that I should be held accounted for whatever I do. If I rob, I'm not necessarily ashamed of it. And if I get caught, I'm not mad because I get some time because I knew what I was doing. You know I'm sitting up here being tried for capital murder, which I was found to be convicted of. Which means that it was proven I did it I guess. But I'm still sitting up here saying that I agree that if I'm found guilty for a crime, then I'm supposed to be punished for it. And I believe in this society, I believe that I've been judged by my peers. And I believe all that. And I know right from wrong. You know I know all of this."
你说：“我不是为了避免死刑才这么说的。我仍然有某些信仰。我仍然认为我应该为我的所作所为负责。如果我抢劫了，我不一定会为此感到羞耻。如果我被抓了，我不会因为我坐牢而生气，因为我知道自己在做什么。你知道，我坐在这里接受死刑谋杀案的审判，并被判定有罪。这意味着我被证明做了这件事，我想。但我仍然坐在这里说，我同意如果我因某项罪行被判有罪，那么我就应该受到惩罚。我相信在这个社会里，我相信我已经受到了同侪的审判。我相信这一切。我知道什么是对，什么是错。你知道，我什么都知道。”
You see I was trying to get that death sentence. I wanted that. I mean everything I could think about that probably would hurt me, I said it. I said it.
你看，我当时是在努力争取那个死刑判决。我想要那个。我的意思是，所有我能想到的可能会伤害我的事情，我都说了。我都说了。
Here is a part in the transcript I'm just looking through. Hold on. Where you say-- this is just a really amazing thing to say to a jury. You say, "Well as far as me being convicted of capital murder, I don't hold no hard feelings toward the jury at all. Let me say this here. As long as they took the evidence and felt me guilty in their own minds as the evidence was presented to them, I don't hold no hard feelings towards them. I'm not against the death penalty." How much of a risk did you think you were taking?
这是笔录里的一段，我正在翻看。等等。你说道——这对陪审团来说真是太令人震惊了。你说：“至于我被判处死刑谋杀罪，我对陪审团没有任何怨恨。让我这么说吧。只要他们根据证据，并且在他们自己的心中感到我有罪，就像证据呈现给他们的那样，我就对他们没有任何怨恨。我不反对死刑。”你觉得你冒了多大的风险？
Where was the risk? There was no risk involved.
哪里有风险？根本没有风险。
Well how much of a risk, how much of a chance did you think you had that you might get executed?
那么，你觉得你被处决的风险有多大，机会有多大？
I probably had a 99.9% chance of being executed. Just like I had a 99.9% chance of spending the rest of my life in prison.
我被处决的可能性大概是99.9%。就像我余生在监狱里度过的可能性是99.9%一样。
So Joe gets what he wants. They sentence him to death. And then his gamble begins. He's on death row five years, 10 years, 15 years. Watches friends there sent to die. And how close did he get to dying?
所以乔得到了他想要的。他们判处他死刑。然后他的赌局开始了。他在死囚牢房呆了五年、十年、十五年。看着身边的朋友被送去死亡。他离死亡有多近？
Oh man, don't even ask me that one. I got denied the District Court. Then i got denied the 8th Circuit. But once you get denied by the United States Supreme Court, you have no more appeals. There's nobody else to appeal that to. And I had got denied by them.
天哪，别问我那个。地区法院驳回了我的上诉。然后第八巡回法院也驳回了。但一旦被美国最高法院驳回，你就再也没有上诉机会了。没有人可以再上诉了。而我已经被他们驳回了。
The same day I was informed I was denied, my lawyer told me then that the attorney general's office has already petitioned the Missouri Supreme Court to set me an execution date.
就在我被告知被驳回的同一天，我的律师告诉我，总检察长办公室已经请求密苏里州最高法院为我设定执行日期。
And so you felt--
所以你觉得——
I felt like I was history. Yeah, I was history. No doubt in my mind. I knew I was history. Everybody else knew I was history. Actually there was an article here in The Pitch Weekly in Kansas City that said "So Long, Joe."
我觉得我成了历史。是的，我成了历史。我心中毫无疑问。我知道我成了历史。其他人都知道我成了历史。实际上，堪萨斯城的《投球周刊》有一篇文章说“再见，乔”。
Well that's what you want to see.
嗯，那就是你想看到的。
That was the cover of their article, "So Long, Joe."
那是他们文章的封面，“再见，乔”。
Yeah, wow. And at that point, did you think maybe I made a mistake choosing the death penalty?
是啊，哇。在那一刻，你有没有想过也许我选择死刑是一个错误？
It probably went through my mind 1,001 times. But I guess the bottom line-- probably I came right back to the same conclusion. It's done. I can't undo it. Don't get me wrong. There were many times where I wanted to just give up, lie in the middle of the floor and just say, I give. Come and kill me.
这可能在我的脑海里闪过了1001次。但我猜底线是——我可能又回到了同样的结论。已经做了。我无法撤回。别误会我。有很多次我想放弃，躺在地板中间说，我认了。来杀我吧。
In the end, his plan worked just like he thought it would. A lawyer from a nonprofit group that does wrongful conviction cases took him on. He got some press. There was actually a documentary film about him. And the Missouri Supreme Court took another look at the evidence in the case and freed him from prison in 2003 after 17 years. All because he went for the death penalty in the first place, he says.
最后，他的计划就像他预想的那样奏效了。一家处理冤假错案的非营利组织的律师接手了他的案子。他获得了一些媒体报道。甚至还有一部关于他的纪录片。密苏里州最高法院重新审视了案子中的证据，并在2003年将他从监狱中释放，当时他已经坐了17年牢。他说，这一切都是因为他最初选择了死刑。
So if you hadn't taken this risk during that trial, do you think you'd be free right now?
所以如果你在审判期间没有冒这个险，你觉得你现在能重获自由吗？
No, no.
不，不会。
You'd still be in there?
你还会被关在里面吗？
Yeah, with life in prison without the possibility of parole. I mean where would I to be able to gain some relief at? I mean I come from a very poor family. I didn't really know anything about the law. Who's going to come and represent me free? That was the only route I could go. I had no choice.
是的，终身监禁不得假释。我的意思是，我能从哪里得到解脱呢？我的意思是，我来自一个非常贫穷的家庭。我真的对法律一无所知。谁会来免费代表我？这是我唯一能走的路。我别无选择。
Well today on our program, we bring you three stories of people who got backed into a corner. And who, like Joe Amrine, made very counter-intuitive choices, choices most of us would never make. Sometimes, as you'll hear, it works out great. Sometimes it works out not so great. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲三个关于被逼入绝境的人的故事。像乔·阿姆林一样，他们做出了非常反直觉的选择，大多数人绝不会做的选择。有时，正如你将听到的，结果非常好。有时结果并不那么好。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是由国际公共广播电台发行的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act One of our program today takes place in a nearly bankrupt sub shop in Seattle, a place where desperate action was necessary. Act Two, in a truck moving across the entire United States. The truck is suffering from what would seem like a nearly unworkable problem. Act Three unfolds in an interrogation room at a top secret government agency. Stay with us.
今天节目的第一幕发生西雅图一家几乎破产的三明治店，一个绝望行动变得必要的地方。第二幕，一辆行驶在整个美国的卡车上。这辆卡车正遭受着一个看似几乎无法解决的问题。第三幕在一个绝密政府机构的审讯室展开。请继续收听。
Act One, Working Class Hero Sandwich. Dawna Lentz was 25, working at a Mexican restaurant for $8.60 an hour, which wasn't enough to pay her share of the rent and save for school. And keep her 1986 Honda from falling apart. So when she noticed a Quiznos franchise opening up across the parking lot from her job, she filled out an application.
第一幕，工人阶级英雄三明治。唐娜·伦茨25岁，在一家墨西哥餐馆工作，时薪8.60美元，这不足以支付她那份房租并为上学存钱。还得维持她那辆1986年的本田车不至于散架。所以当她注意到她工作地点停车场对面开了一家Quiznos特许经营店时，她填了一份申请。
It was supposed to be an easy second income. Making sandwiches part time seemed simple enough. But she ended up backed into this corner where she had to make the kind of decision you or I would probably never make. Shirleen Holt tells what happened.
这本应是一份轻松的第二收入。做兼职三明治似乎很简单。但她最终被逼入这个角落，不得不做出你我可能永远不会做的决定。雪莉恩·霍尔特讲述了发生的事情。
The first hint that this store might run into problems was the job interview, or in Dawna's case, the lack of one.
这家店可能遇到问题的第一个迹象是面试，或者在唐娜的例子中，根本没有面试。
I went it. And he handed me the handbook. And he goes, OK, I'll call you when we open the restaurant. I'm like, OK, that was the easiest interview I've ever been on.
我进去，他递给我手册。他说，好，我们开店的时候我给你打电话。我心想，好吧，这是我参加过的最简单的面试。
The restaurant was owned by three immigrants from India. One was a likable but nervous man named Navi. He was supposed to manage the place but he never ran a restaurant before. The others were a husband and wife team who were supposed to be silent partners. To Dawna, Navi seemed to be doing well at first, but the partners didn't think so.
这家店由三名来自印度的移民拥有。其中一个是讨人喜欢但很紧张的男人，名叫纳维。他本应管理这个地方，但他以前从未经营过餐馆。其他人是一对夫妇，他们应该是默契的合伙人。对唐娜来说，纳维起初似乎做得不错，但合伙人并不这么认为。
They would call him and say that he was spending too much money on food and not enough money was coming in. Just nit picking about things. We would get wonderful scores on our evaluations when corporate would come in. And they would pick them apart on him. He didn't smoke for five or six years. He stopped smoking. And then once he started at the restaurant, and they started giving him a hard time, he was smoking. He was throwing up before he was working. He couldn't come into the store without getting sick. He just was done with it.
他们会打电话给他，说他在食物上花的钱太多，进来的钱不够。就各种琐事挑剔他。当公司的人来视察时，我们的评估得分会非常好。而他们会因为他而挑剔这些得分。他有五六年不抽烟了。他戒烟了。然后自从他在餐馆开始工作，他们开始为难他，他又开始抽烟了。他在上班前呕吐。他不进店就觉得恶心。他真的受够了。
One Sunday night about a month after the store opened, Navi pulled Dawna aside.
店开业大约一个月后的一个周日晚上，纳维把唐娜拉到一边。
And he was like, Dawna I can't do this anymore. They're making my life hard. I miss my family. I want to go home to my wife. And it's not worth it. I'll give up all my money that I put into this. I'm just going to go. And I was like you can't go yet. You're leaving me here. I haven't been trained to do anything in this store for this company. I don't know what they want. And he was like I can't do it anymore. And so he says I'm sorry, I am leaving. I quit. So that's when things started going bad.
他说，唐娜，我做不下去了。他们让我的生活变得很困难。我想念我的家人。我想回妻子身边。这不值得。我放弃我投入的所有钱。我只是要走了。我说，你现在还不能走。你把我丢在这里。我没有接受过这家店或这家公司的任何培训。我不知道他们想要什么。他说我做不下去了。所以他说对不起，我要走了。我辞职了。这就是事情开始变糟的时候。
Dawna called the other owners and told them what happened. And they took over, which only made things worse.
唐娜打电话给其他所有者告诉他们发生了什么。他们接手了，这只会让事情变得更糟。
The wife came in and started pushing the employees around. And saying they're not doing things right. And we need to do things like this. And she hung out for probably about an hour, if that, every day for a month. And then she was gone. I called her and I was like, what am I supposed to do with this store? Are you guys coming in? Or what are you leaving me?
妻子来了，开始对员工推推搡搡。说他们做事不对。我们需要这样那样做。她每天待大约一个小时，如果有一个月的话。然后她就走了。我打电话给她，我问，我该怎么处理这家店？你们要过来吗？还是你们要把我撇下？
And their exact words were, "Dawna, we're giving this store to you. Take care of it." And I'm like, I don't know how.
他们的原话是：“唐娜，我们把这家店交给你了。照顾好它。”我心想，我不知道怎么做。
Dawna still doesn't know why the owners abandoned the store. Maybe they were too busy with their other businesses. Maybe they had money problems. Whatever the reason, suddenly she and her crew were alone. By now, Dawna was working there full time. It was her only job.
唐娜仍然不知道为什么老板们放弃了这家店。也许他们太忙于其他生意了。也许他们有资金问题。无论什么原因，突然间她和她的团队孤立无援。那时，唐娜在那里全职工作。这是她唯一的工作。
She called Quiznos' regional office every day, sometimes more. They told here there was nothing they could do. They didn't own the business, the franchiser did. But Dawna and the other employees stayed, figuring help would come. Her first duty as unofficial manager was to order food.
她每天给Quiznos区域办公室打电话，有时还不止一次。他们告诉她他们无能为力。他们不拥有这家店，特许经营商才拥有。但唐娜和其他员工留下了，想着帮助会到来。她作为非官方经理的第一个任务是订购食物。
So I started talking to these distributors and stuff. And I called them and I'm like, I've never done this before. Help. And people are like, Oh don't worry. It's OK. We'll work with you.
所以我开始和那些分销商谈话之类的。我打电话给他们，我说，我从来没做过这个。救命。人们说，噢别担心。没事的。我们会和你合作的。
This is how Dawna learned how to run the business. She asked questions. She improvised. And things were OK at first. Food was coming in. The payroll service was sending checks. Every day she'd deposit more money in the store's bank account than she was spending. But what Dawna didn't know was that the account was being bled dry by automatic withdrawals. Quiznos corporate was taking its cut. Then the lenders. Then even small things like the laundry service.
这就是唐娜学会经营生意的方式。她提问。她即兴发挥。起初情况还好。食物进来了。工资服务在发支票。每天她存进店里银行账户的钱都比她花的要多。但唐娜不知道的是，该账户正因自动扣款而被掏空。Quiznos公司在拿走他们的分成。然后是贷款方。甚至像洗衣服务这样的小开销。
It took about not even a full month for us to start going really rapidly downhill. Things started bouncing through checking accounts. So food wasn't coming in. And they started making it pay on delivery. And then we started getting, if you don't pay, we'll turn it off notices. Or, we'll stop serving you notices. And also we got stuck with checks not being paid, bouncing checks.
大概没花满一个月，我们就开始迅速走下坡路了。事情开始在支票账户中跳票。所以食物进不来了。他们开始要求货到付款。然后我们开始收到，如果你不付款，我们将断供的通知。或者，我们将停止为你服务的通知。而且我们还陷入了支票无法支付、跳票的困境。
Our payday was on December 24, Christmas Eve. Everybody wants to go Christmas shopping. So I gave them their checks. And they all went over to the bank and tried to cash their checks. And all the bank tellers laughed at them because there was no money in the account. And so that's when we have to start taking money out of the drawer.
我们的发薪日是12月24日，平安夜。每个人都想去买圣诞礼物。所以我给了他们支票。他们都去银行尝试兑现支票。银行出纳员嘲笑他们，因为账户里没钱。所以这就是我们不得不开始从收银机里拿钱的时候。
She pad employees out of the drawer. She paid suppliers out of the drawer. She paid the rent out of the drawer.
她从收银机里付给员工工资。她从收银机里支付给供应商。她从收银机里付房租。
That got very, very slim pickings there. My deposit turned into like $200 a night. And so probably after money started running dry, I was probably earning maybe $1 a day. And so that's when the employees started getting paid maybe every other night or every three nights. And that's when I lost the majority of my employees.
那里变得非常非常拮据。我的存款变成了每晚大约200美元。所以钱开始枯竭后，我可能每天只能赚1美元。所以那是员工开始可能每隔一晚或每三晚才拿到工资的时候。这也是我失去大部分员工的时候。
Still, Dawna didn't quit. Not because she felt so loyal to Quiznos, and not because she loved the challenge. She stayed because the economy was tough. And she was worried she might not find another job, even a job that paid $1 a day was better than no job at all. Also--
尽管如此，唐娜还是没辞职。不是因为她对Quiznos感到那么忠诚，也不是因为她喜欢这个挑战。她留下是因为经济不景气。她担心找不到另一份工作，即使是一份每天只挣1美元的工作也比没工作好。还有——
I thought there was hope somewhere. Maybe this is just a phase. But I didn't think it would ever get to the point that it did.
我以为某处有希望。也许这只是一个阶段。但我没想到会达到那样的程度。
I visited the restaurant when things were at their worst. And it was like walking into a store in Russia after the ruble collapsed. Nothing on the shelves, hardly any customers, so quiet you could hear the appliances humming. It's weird to be in fast food place with a clean floors, and the brightly colored tables, and everything in its place except the food.
我在情况最糟的时候去过那家餐馆。就像走进俄罗斯卢布崩盘后的一家商店。货架上什么都没有，几乎没有顾客，安静得能听到电器运转的嗡嗡声。在一个快餐店里，地板很干净，色彩鲜艳的桌子，一切都在原位，除了食物，这感觉很奇怪。
There were little handwritten signs all over the store. Each nozzle on the soda dispenser had its own "Out Of Order" note taped to it. Except for Vanilla Coke. People hate Vanilla Coke. One customer, a tall professional woman, looked at the soda machine, laughed, and asked for a large, Out of Order. "With ice or without?" Dawna deadpanned.
店里到处都是手写的小标志。苏打水分配器的每个喷嘴上都贴着一张“故障”的纸条。除了香草可乐。人们讨厌香草可乐。一位顾客，一位高大的职业女性，看着苏打水机，笑了笑，要了一大杯“故障”。“要冰还是不要冰？”唐娜面无表情地问。
We started writing signs to warn them beforehand, OK, they were out of this, this, this, this. Because how do you explain to somebody, I don't have any bread even though I'm a sub shop? Like, I'm sorry, I don't have any bread? I don't even know where to start from that.
我们开始写标志来预先警告他们，好吧，我们没有这个、那个、那个、那个。因为你怎么跟人解释，虽然我是开三明治店的，但我没面包？比如，对不起，我没面包了？我甚至不知道从哪里开始解释。
At the prep table, they only had that processed lunch meat turkey you get at a grocery store, some roast beef, but none of the normal Quiznos sauces. No honey bourbon mustard, no zesty grill sauce, no creamy bacon Alfredo, no raspberry chipotle. In the back room, it was just as bad.
在准备台上，他们只有那种在杂货店买的加工火鸡肉、一些烤牛肉，但没有正常的Quiznos酱料。没有蜂蜜波本芥末酱，没有香辣烧烤酱，没有奶油培根阿尔弗雷多酱，没有树莓辣椒酱。在后屋，情况一样糟糕。
This is going to be cold. This is our freezer. There was one box, and that was Philly cheese steak. And that was it. I had no cookies, no soups, no nothing. Right here is where soups are. When we were out of stuff, we didn't have soups, so there was nothing there. There were no pots, no pans, no dishes, nothing. it was just empty. Right over here is where we would prep. And it was usually empty because there was nothing to prep.
这里会很冷。这是我们的冷冻柜。只有一个盒子，那是费城芝士牛排。就这样。我没有饼干，没有汤，什么都没有。这里就是汤的地方。当我们没东西时，就没有汤，所以什么都没有。没有锅，没有平底锅，没有盘子，什么都没有。它只是空的。就在这里是我们准备食物的地方。它通常是空的，因为没什么可准备的。
Dawna made a spreadsheet on her home computer. Every night, she'd subtract the day's costs from sales. The numbers always came up negative. It frustrated her, kept her up at night. Every morning with money from the till, Dawna bought lunch meat at Cash and Carry. Then she'd drive to other Quiznos stores around Seattle for the special bread. She bought a few bags at a time, rationing the supply so the night crew would have enough for their shift. Not that the customers appreciated it.
唐娜在她的家用电脑上做了一个电子表格。每天晚上，她会从销售额中减去当天的成本。数字总是负数。这让她很沮丧，晚上睡不着觉。每天早上用收银机里的钱，唐娜在Cash and Carry超市买午餐肉。然后她开车去西雅图周围的其他Quiznos店买特制面包。她一次买几袋，定量供应，这样夜班人员就有足够的面包上班。并不是顾客们对此心存感激。
At first people would just walk out. And then it got to the point where people are like, why are you even open? Why do you stay here? And then after the first couple times of people getting irritated, I put up another sign telling them not to be mad at us. It's not our fault.
起初人们只会走开。然后到了人们说，你们为什么还要开店？你们为什么要待在这里？然后在那几次人们感到恼火之后，我又贴了另一个标志，告诉他们不要对我们生气。这不是我们的错。
This is what the sign said.
这是标志上写的内容。
"Due to bad owners, we are out of a lot of things. Please do not be mad at the employees or manager. We're really sorry, and please be patient."
“由于糟糕的老板，我们很多东西都缺货。请不要生员工或经理的气。我们真的很抱歉，请耐心等待。”
The day that we didn't have I think chicken or something, a customer came down and was like, you know what, you're good for nothing, incompetent. What's the purpose of you even being here? And I just looked at him and I was so shocked for words. I had nothing to say to him. And it hurt me. It hit me really hard.
有一天我想我们没有鸡肉或其他什么东西，一个顾客走过来，说，你知道吗，你一无是处，无能。你待在这里到底有什么意义？我只是看着他，震惊得说不出话来。我没什么可对他说。这伤害了我。这对我打击很大。
Why?
为什么？
Because I was trying so hard and that people couldn't see that I was trying so hard. I mean my employees saw it. But the customers were just blowing it off like this was an everyday thing. And it wasn't.
因为我一直在努力，而人们看不到我一直在努力。我的员工看到了。但顾客们只是忽略了它，好像这是一件每天都在发生的事情。其实不然。
So what sort of person comes to a sandwich shop that doesn't have any food? When I visited the store back then, I saw a lot of first time customers, plus other people who worked in the strip mall who were curious to see how bad things were getting. Then there were customers liked Tim, a local delivery man. For him, habit and convenience were apparently more important than quality, variety and freedom of choice.
那么，什么样的人会来到一家没有食物的三明治店呢？当我当时访问这家店时，我看到很多第一次来的顾客，还有其他在那个购物中心工作、好奇看看情况到底有多糟的人。然后有像蒂姆这样的顾客，一名当地的送货员。对他来说，习惯和方便显然比质量、多样性和选择自由更重要。
I walk in the door, and whatever's left she made me to eat. I still showed up. I was here every day. And then every day it was one thing short of another. Out of bread, and then it was out of meat. And then it was one thing or another. Yeah, I was wondering if I was going to get a napkin with some lettuce on it. So I wasn't for sure.
我走进门，剩下什么她就让我吃什么。我还是会出现。我每天都在这里。然后每天都少一样东西。没有面包，然后是没肉了。然后就是这东西或那东西。是的，我当时在想我会不会拿到一张上面带有一片生菜的餐巾纸。所以我也不确定。
Dawna kept calling the Quiznos people. One Sunday, she told them she'd run out of bread. Again, they told her they couldn't step in. Bread or no bread, she had to keep the store open. Then the media got a hold of the story and suddenly, everything changed. Quiznos headquarters sent in reinforcements, brought in food, paid the workers back wages.
唐娜一直给Quiznos的人打电话。有一个周日，她告诉他们面包用完了。他们又一次告诉她，他们不能介入。不管有没有面包，她都得保持店铺营业。然后媒体得到了这个故事，突然间，一切都变了。Quiznos总部派来了增援部队，带来了食物，支付了员工的欠薪。
I never saw more people here in my life.
我一生中从未见过这里有这么多人。
Again, Tim, the customer and delivery man.
再次是蒂姆，那位顾客和送货员。
They were so over-staffed it was unbelievable. They had people just standing around just to ask you, Hey, how are you doing? And they were blowing smoke talking about, Oh, as soon as we heard, we rushed right on down here and took care of it. And I lose my job if I took that long to get a package to somebody, you know what I'm saying?
他们人手过剩得令人难以置信。他们有人只是站在那里，就为了问你，嘿，你怎么样？他们吹牛说，噢，我们一听说就赶快过来解决了。如果我花那么长时间才把包裹送到某人手里，我就丢工作了，你懂我的意思吗？
I tried to speak with one of the Quiznos people Dawna dealt with, but was redirected to a spokesperson, Stacie Lange, Quiznos vice president of public relations.
我试图采访唐娜打过交道的Quiznos的一位人员，但被转接给了一位发言人，史黛西·兰格，Quiznos公共关系副总裁。
Unfortunately, we had a glitch in our system where the regionalized people did not communicate the information back to corporate about what was going on. Otherwise we would have stepped in a lot sooner with support. The best we can ascertain of why it didn't communicate back to corporate is that the regional folks were aware that we had a new franchise owner in the system who is supposedly only weeks away from assuming responsibility of this store. And they recognized that Dawna and the team had things going very well at the store from their perspective.
不幸的是，我们的系统出了故障，区域人员没有把正在发生的事情反馈给总部。否则我们早就会介入提供支持了。我们能查明的关于为什么没有反馈给总部的最好解释是，区域人员知道系统里有一位新的特许经营所有者，据称几周内就要承担这家店的责任。而且他们认为从他们的角度来看，唐娜和团队把店经营得很好。
Very well? Is that how they put it?
很好？他们是这么说的吗？
Well in their case, they were keeping things operating by their standards. Clearly not by corporate standards.
在他们看来，他们是按照他们的标准在维持运营。显然不符合企业标准。
Stacie explained that after all this happened, Quiznos flew Dawna to its headquarters in Denver. She got to meet the company president, and she went through formal management training.
史黛西解释说，这一切发生后，Quiznos把唐娜飞到了丹佛的总部。她见到了公司总裁，并接受了正式的管理培训。
Did she get a raise to manager salary?
她拿到经理工资的加薪了吗？
Absolutely. What had happened is there's a bump in pay, hourly pay, for a manager position versus a line employee. So she was able to reap the benefits of that.
绝对。发生的是，经理职位相对于一线员工的工资，每小时工资有提升。所以她能够享受到这个好处。
The benefit was a $1 raise to $8.60 an hour, the same that Dawna was making at the Mexican restaurant five months earlier. She wasn't paid overtime for the 12 hour days she worked. She wasn't compensated for the customer abuse or the pressure from vendors who wanted their money. But in a weird way, those struggles brought their own kind of reward. After years of minimum wage jobs, getting ordered around by all sorts of people, it's useful to learn that the bosses and owners don't know anything you couldn't figure out on your own. Dawna had stopped thinking of herself as a line worker. And she'd started thinking of herself as a manager.
好处是每小时加薪1美元，达到8.60美元，这和唐娜五个月前在墨西哥餐馆赚的一样多。她那每天12小时的工作没有加班费。她没有因为顾客的虐待或想要回钱的供应商的压力而得到补偿。但以一种奇怪的方式，这些挣扎带来了它们自己的一种回报。经过多年拿最低工资的工作，被各种各样的人指使，学习到老板和所有者并不了解任何你自己无法弄清楚的事情，是很有用的。唐娜已经不再把自己当作一线工人。她开始把自己当作一名经理。
I didn't need anybody else. I needed money, but who doesn't? But I didn't need anybody else. I was on a major test of my whole life. And taking on something like that was a big responsibility. And it was dropped on me. And I do understand that. But I chose to stick it in there. And so therefore I chose that responsibility. And I feel it would look good on an application, voluntary work for a sub shop. Where else could you get something like that?
我不需要任何人。我需要钱，但谁不需要呢？但我不需要别人。我经历了我一生中最大的考验。承担这样的事情是一项巨大的责任。它落在我的头上。我明白这一点。但我选择坚持下去。因此我选择了那种责任。我觉得这对申请工作很有利，为三明治店做志愿者工作。还能去哪里得到这样的经历？
Eventually the publicity died down. And when it did, the corporate people left. And again, Dawna and the others were on their own, still paying themselves out of the till, still coming up short. For a while it looked like the company had found a buyer. Then the deal fell through. Dawna thought about buying the place herself. She even talked to people at the bank. But she didn't earn enough to qualify for the loan. So six months after it opened, Quiznos shop on Holman Road, "My Store," as Dawna used to call it, shut down.
最终，宣传平息了。当它平息时，公司的人离开了。唐娜和其他人又孤立无援了，还在用收银机里的钱给自己发工资，还是入不敷出。有一段时间，看起来公司找到了一位买家。后来交易失败了。唐娜考虑过自己买下这个地方。她甚至和银行的人谈过。但她赚的钱不够申请贷款。所以六个月后，霍尔曼路的Quiznos店，“我的店”，正如唐娜曾经称呼它的那样，关门了。
Dawna took a manager in training job at Radio Shack making $8 an hour plus commission. She's still waiting for her last paycheck from Quiznos.
唐娜在Radio Shack找到了一份经理培训工作，时薪8美元加佣金。她还在等Quiznos发她最后一份工资。
Shirleen Holt is a business reporter at the Seattle Times.
雪莉恩·霍尔特是《西雅图时报》的一名商业记者。
[MUSIC - "INVINCIBLE" BY OK GO] Coming up, backed into a corner on thousands of miles of interstate highway. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
[音乐 - OK GO乐队的《INVINCIBLE》] 接下来，在几千英里的州际公路上被逼入绝境。稍后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Backed Into a Corner, stories of people who are forced into making decisions they really do not want to make. We've arrive at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Don't Drive Like My Brother.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，为你带来各种不同种类的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，《被逼入绝境》，讲述那些被迫做出他们真的不想做的决定的人们的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，开车别像我弟弟那样。
Like our story in Act One, this is a story about somebody who just needed a job. And that is what put him into the position where he ended up doing things that most of us would probably avoid. Charles Johnson had a wife and daughter. And he was out of work, and he looked around. And he was so desperate that he ended up in a job where he lacked one crucial qualification, a critical qualification you'd think. And yet somehow he made it work for years. Jonathan Menjivar explains.
像我们第一幕中的故事一样，这是一个关于一个只需要一份工作的人的故事。正是这一点使他处于最终做了我们大多数人可能会避免的事情的境地。查尔斯·约翰逊有一个妻子和女儿。他失业了，四处寻找。他太绝望了，以至于最终得到了一份工作，但他缺乏一个关键资格，你可能会认为这是一个至关重要的资格。然而不知何故，他坚持干了几年。乔纳森·门吉瓦解释说。
Charles Johnson was a trucker, a long haul trucker who went everywhere. And he did it without knowing how to read. Couldn't read highway signs. Couldn't read a map. It got him into all sorts of trouble, like when he was hauling stuff to New Jersey from New York and had no idea how to decipher the signs on the George Washington Bridge. Hundreds of feet in the air, 12 lanes of traffic, and he's hauling 80,000 pounds, enough weight that you never forget it's there.
查尔斯·约翰逊是一名卡车司机，一名去过各地的长途卡车司机。他这样做时还不识字。读不懂高速公路标志。看不懂地图。这让他陷入了各种麻烦，比如当他从纽约运送东西到新泽西，完全不知道如何解读乔治·华盛顿大桥上的标志。在数百英尺的高空中，12条车道，他拉着8万磅的东西，重量大到让你永远不会忘记它的存在。
So I got mixed up. So I had to call a truck, Mayday, mayday. I'm up on the bridge. I'm stuck. Get me down. Get me down. I'm trying to go Jersey. If I miss it, I have to go all the way back around. And I always thought of that, I said here I am up here and can't read. Would anyone believe this?
所以我弄糊涂了。所以我不得不打电话给卡车，五月天，五月天。我在大桥上。我被困住了。让我下去。让我下去。我正试图去新泽西。如果我错过了，我得绕很远的路回来。我总是想，我说我在这里，却不识字。有人会相信吗？
He was just one of those kids who never caught on to reading. He grew up poor in Clarendon, Arkansas, where his family worked as sharecroppers. Charles had asthma, was a sickly kid. And he stayed home from school a lot. And by the third grade, it was pretty clear he wasn't keeping up. As he got older he was so good at sports, pulling in 30 points a game for the basketball team, they just passed him from grade to grade.
他只是那些从来没学会阅读的孩子之一。他在阿肯色州的克拉伦登长大，家里是佃农。查尔斯有哮喘，是个病弱的孩子。他经常旷课待在家里。到三年级时，很明显他跟不上。随着年龄增长，他在体育方面非常出色，篮球队每场比赛能拿30分，他们就让他逐年升级。
By his 30's, he'd moved to St. Louis and got married and did a bunch of different jobs. He washed dishes for a while. For about six months he ran a gas station his brother owned. But it never seemed like he could support a family on any of those jobs. His brother Paul was making good money as a truck driver. And it seemed to Charles like it was something he could do too. He found out that this trucking company, JH Ware, was training and hiring drivers.
到了30多岁，他搬到了圣路易斯，结婚并做了各种各样的工作。他洗过一段时间盘子。有六个月左右，他经营了他兄弟拥有的一家加油站。但似乎他靠这些工作养不活家。他的兄弟保罗作为卡车司机赚了不少钱。这对查尔斯来说似乎是他也能做的事情。他发现那家名为JH Ware的卡车公司正在培训和招聘司机。
So he signed up. The details he didn't understand, like the words on the truck's instrument panel, he just ignored.
于是他报名了。他不理解的细节，比如卡车仪表板上的词，他只是忽略了。
The gauges, whatever they were saying, you really, really didn't pay that much attention. They was just there. You just know that you have to work and make a living. You know what I'm saying? I mean you aren't going to let no gauges stop $400 or $500 coming in your home for a week.
仪表，不管它们在说什么，你真的，真的没有太注意。它们只是在那里。你只知道你必须工作来养家糊口。你懂我的意思吗？我的意思是，你不会让任何仪表挡住你每周挣回家的400或500美元。
And I just knew I could do the manual part, how to shift a 21-speed, 9-speed. But then we'd go in the classroom and I would flunk. I would fail everything. I didn't know what they were talking about. How to get this stuff off of paper and put it down. I couldn't do it.
我只知道我能做体力活，如何操作21档、9档变速箱。但然后我们会进入教室，我会不及格。我什么都失败了。我不知道他们在谈论什么。如何把这些东西从纸上弄下来并写下来。我做不到。
What made this even harder is that at the time, no one knew Charles couldn't read. Not his wife, not any of his friends, nobody. So it's not like he could just ask for extra help from a teacher because he'd risk outing himself. Luckily for him, he did have an older brother, a really, really nice older brother.
让这件事更难的是，当时没人知道查尔斯不识字。他的妻子不知道，他的任何朋友都不知道，没人知道。所以他不能只是向老师寻求额外帮助，因为他会冒着暴露自己的风险。对他来说幸运的是，他有一个哥哥，一个真的，真的很好的哥哥。
A lady from the personnel office at JH Ware called me.
JH Ware人事办公室的一位女士给我打了电话。
This is Paul Kelly, Charles' oldest brother, the one who had always found jobs for him and helped him out. Paul's also been driving a truck for 30 years.
这是保罗·凯利，查尔斯最大的哥哥，那个一直为他找工作并帮助他的人。保罗也开了30年卡车。
OK she says your brother is trying to get a job with us. And asked me if there was any way that I could come and attend the class that he was taking for a week. And she says, I would sure give him a job if you come down and help him. And I said well I'm working right now. So what I did, I took a week's vacation off. I got my gear together. And I went down to Fullerton, Missouri and I spent a week in class with him. The orientation did require some reading. I was sitting right there basically by him and making sure that everything that he checked was correct.
好吧，她说你弟弟正在尝试加入我们公司。她问我是否能去参加他要上一周的课。她说，如果你能来帮他，我肯定会给他一份工作。我说我正在工作。所以我做的是，我休了一周假。我收拾好装备。我去了密苏里州的富勒顿，在那儿和他一起上了一周的课。入职培训确实需要阅读。我基本上就坐在他旁边，确保他检查的每一件事都是正确的。
And what they would do is give you a world map and ask you the closest route to a certain place in the United States. How would you get there? And I had to teach him the straight line is the closest route to any place.
他们会做的是给你一张世界地图，问你到美国某个地方的最短路线。你怎么到那里？我不得不教他直线是到任何地方的最短路线。
Did it seem like he was reading along with you even if he was slow?
他看起来像是和你一起读，即使他读得很慢？
Exactly.
完全正确。
Once the week of classes was done, Paul took Charles on a trial run down to Atlanta. They drove back through the Carolinas, up over Black Mountain in Tennessee, where Paul taught Charles how to ride the air in his brakes properly so that they wouldn't burn up. How to put it in grandma to slow down. Miraculously, Charles passed the written part of the driving test, which was multiple choice. He used a special technique.
一周的课程结束后，保罗带着查尔斯进行了一次前往亚特兰大的试运行。他们开车回经过卡罗来纳州，越过田纳西州的黑山，在那里保罗教查尔斯如何正确使用刹车空气，以免刹车烧毁。如何挂低速档来减速。奇迹般的是，查尔斯通过了驾驶测试的笔试部分，那是选择题。他使用了一种特殊技巧。
I just guessed. Eenie meenie miney mo.
我只是猜。瞎猜。
He got the job. So there he was, license in hand and really no idea how he was going to pull it off. The job worked like this. The dispatcher gave him what truckers call a bill, which listed the address he was supposed to deliver to and when they expected him. That's it. No directions, no advice at all about how to get there. Sometimes if he had seen the name of the state before, Charles could make it out on the bill. Sometimes he couldn't but his dispatcher would say enough so they knew we had to go to Kansas City, and that he should head west.
他得到了这份工作。所以他就这样，手里拿着执照，真的不知道他该怎么干下去。这份工作是这样运作的。调度员给了他所谓的提单，上面列出了他应该送达的地址和预期时间。就这样。没有路线，没有关于如何到达那里的任何建议。有时如果他以前见过那个州的名字，查尔斯能在提单上分辨出来。有时他看不懂，但他的调度员会说足够的信息，让他知道我们要去堪萨斯城，并且他应该向西走。
And then you go around truck drivers and you say, I'm going to Kansas City. Anybody going? And then one person would say, yeah come over here. And so I'd say, man, when are you going to take off? He'd say, I'm going to take off in about two hours. I'd say can you wait on me? I'll try to go with you. He'd say, well yeah I'll wait on you. You'll be my back man. We'll talk on the radio all the way up. That's how you get there too.
然后你绕着卡车司机问，我要去堪萨斯城。有人去吗？然后一个人会说，是啊过来。所以我说，嘿，你什么时候出发？他说，我大约两小时后出发。我说你能等我吗？我试着和你一起走。他说，好吧，我会等你的。你会成为我的后援。我们会全程通过无线电交流。这也是你到达那里的方式。
But still, those methods only work some of the time. And that's where his brother Paul came in.
但即便如此，这些方法只在有时有效。这就是他兄弟保罗发挥作用的地方。
So what Charles would do if he had a problem with his directions, well he would call me and say, hey Paul, I'm going to this place. How do I get there? The first time he called me, I believe it was about the second or third day.
所以如果查尔斯在路线上遇到问题，他会打电话给我说，嘿保罗，我要去这个地方。我怎么去？他第一次给我打电话，我相信大约是在第二天或第三天。
I sad hello Paul. And he said, yeah, what's going on?
我说喂保罗。他说，是啊，怎么了？
Paul, I have a load going to, I want to say, Philadelphia.
保罗，我有一趟货要去，我想说是费城。
And then he said you going to Philly. Well you take route boom, boom, boom.
然后他说你要去费城。好吧，你走路线嗡，嗡，嗡。
You're going to take Interstate 70 to New Stanton. New Stanton you pick up Interstate 76. And you take 76. You get over to Breezewood, Pennsylvania.
你要走70号州际公路到新斯坦顿。新斯坦顿你要接76号州际公路。然后你走76号。你到达宾夕法尼亚州的布里兹伍德。
All right, let's stop that right there. Now if you're a person who reads, you'd be writing all this down. And Paul always assumed that's what Charles was doing.
好了，我们在那儿停一下。如果你是一个会阅读的人，你会把这些都写下来。保罗一直认为那是查尔斯在做的事情。
I want to say he was writing it down. Because he would repeat it. Let me tell you now, I'm sitting at home, I don't know. He got there.
我想说他写下来了。因为他会重复一遍。我现在告诉你，我坐在家里，我不知道。他到了那里。
I had my ABCs down.
我掌握了ABC。
Charles couldn't read, but he knew his alphabet. He just had to coax someone into spelling the words for him.
查尔斯不识字，但他知道字母表。他只需要诱导别人为他拼写单词。
Then I'd tell him, how do you spell that again? Or something like that. And he'd tell me, C-I-T-Y, city. I could write that down.
然后我会告诉他，那个再怎么拼？或者类似的东西。他会告诉我，C-I-T-Y，城市。我能把它写下来。
He wasn't a worrisome person that had to get me out the bed 24/7. But I got up quite a bit. So actually I was his man map by phone. Matter of fact, I had a map out just for him. Yeah I had a map at home just for Charles on my dinner table.
他不是一个让人担心、不得不24/7把他从床上拉起来的人。但我确实起得很频繁。所以实际上我是他电话里的导航地图。事实上，我专门为他放了一张地图。是的，我在家里的餐桌上专门为查尔斯放了一张地图。
Paul says Charles would call him three or four times a week. And sometimes as often as 10 times a week. But even with Paul's help, Charles had a hard time making sense of the route. He still had to make the place names correspond to what he was seeing on those big green signs over the highway, which he calls boards. He could read numbers. And sometimes he could recognize a word. But it wasn't exactly reading.
保罗说查尔斯一周会给他打三四次电话。有时甚至一周十次。但即使有保罗的帮助，查尔斯也很难理解路线。他仍然必须让地名与他在高速公路上方那些绿色大标志上看到的相对应，他称之为布告板。他能读懂数字。有时他能认出一个词。但这并不完全是阅读。
It was like matching up. Pennsylvania on my paper. Then it would be on the board there. You are now on the Pennsylvania Turnpike. And it would match up so I knew I was there. As far as reading it, no.
这就像配对。我的纸上有宾夕法尼亚。然后标志牌上也会有。你现在在宾夕法尼亚收费公路上。它们对应起来，所以我知道我在那儿。至于读出来，不。
But even when he got to the city or town on his bill, he still wasn't done. Now he had to find out the exact address. On his bill for instance, it would say 1925 Light Road. But Charles didn't know that, so he'd have to ask somebody. Usually his best bet was to find a cop.
但即使他到了提单上的城市或城镇，他还没完成任务。现在他必须找出具体地址。例如在提单上，它会写着光路1925号。但查尔斯不知道，所以他得问别人。通常他最好的选择是找个警察。
I would give it to the police officer. And he would say, oh Light Road right down there. Then I got Light Road in my head and I don't forget it. And so he said go here. I said, could you write it down for me?
我会把它交给警察。他会说，噢，光路就在那边。然后我就记住了光路，我就不会忘记了。所以他说去这儿。我说，你能帮我写下来吗？
So Charles figured out a way to do the job. But the way he was making it work was also making him fail at the job because he was always late.
所以查尔斯想出了一种做这份工作的方法。但他做这份工作的方式也让他在这份工作中失败了，因为他总是迟到。
And when you are late, they take late payments out of your check. And so I'd call my wife, say, you get to check? She said, yeah I got it. It was so small. I didn't say honey I can't read. I had to shut my mouth. It was a nightmare. I couldn't read. I was confused on the road. Wasn't bringing enough money in. The loads was always late. Confusion, confusion, confusion. What can you do?
当你迟到时，他们会从你的支票里扣除滞纳金。所以我会打电话给我妻子，说，你收到支票了吗？她说，是啊收到了。太少了。我没说亲爱的我不会读。我只能闭嘴。这是一场噩梦。我不会读。我在路上很困惑。没带回足够的钱。货物总是迟到。困惑，困惑，困惑。你能做什么？
Did you ever feel like you should just quit?
你有没有觉得你应该直接辞职？
Every day, no matter what Jonathan-- I'd say I have to do it. I took the bills. I told the old lady and my daughter that I would be going to New York. And I had to get to New York.
每一天，不管乔纳森——我会说我必须做。我接了提单。我告诉老太太和我的女儿我要去纽约。我必须去纽约。
So he was only driving a truck to keep his family together. But he never made good money at it. And being away from home so much ended up hurting his marriage. Before long, he and his wife split up. He quit trucking after he fell asleep at the wheel and drifted into a ditch. His brother Paul was glad he finally quit. He'd worried about him every day he was on the road. And when he looks back on it, he's not sure why he never figured out that Charles couldn't read.
所以他开车只是为了维持家庭。但他从未因此赚到好钱。离开家太久最终伤害了他的婚姻。不久后，他和妻子分开了。他在开车时睡着并漂移到沟里后辞职了。他的兄弟保罗很高兴他终于辞职了。他每天他在路上时都为他担心。当他回首往事时，他不知道为什么他从来没发现查尔斯不识字。
And why I felt like that, I don't have a clue. That's strange, isn't it? Charles was-- I don't know if you spent much time around a person who's not that intelligent as far as books go and reading. Growing up in our environment, there was quite a bit of this around. And it was something that we didn't pay special attention to. So Charles is news I guess to your guys' ears. But like I say, I worked around it all my life. And these guys can fake you out. I mean you don't really have a clue that they don't really understand how to read. And he actually got away with it.
至于为什么我会有这种感觉，我毫无头绪。这很奇怪，不是吗？查尔斯是——我不知道你是否花过很多时间与一个在书本和阅读方面没那么聪明的人在一起。在我们成长的环境中，这种情况相当多。这是我们没特别注意的事情。所以查尔斯的新闻我想对你们的耳朵来说很新鲜。但就像我说的，我一生都在这种环境下工作。这些人能骗过你。我的意思是，你真的不知道他们根本不懂怎么读。他竟然混过去了。
It frightens me more now than it did then because I didn't know much about it. But now when he told me that he was having such a problem, then I have feelings for him.
这比当时更让我害怕，因为当时我对此了解不多。但现在当他告诉我他有这个问题时，我为他感到难过。
So where are we going to go? I know the direction. This is south we're headed. Charles reads now. So driving is different for him. And so he took me for a drive to show me what that was like.
所以我们要去哪儿？我知道方向。我们正朝着南方。查尔斯现在识字了。所以对他来说，开车完全不同。所以他带我开车去向我展示那是怎样的。
So before when you would drive down, would you be able to tell what--
那么以前当你开车时，你能分辨出什么——
I wouldn't notice any of those signs. All I did was notice my target from A to Z. Now as far as reading the signs like "For Sale" right here, I didn't read that. I didn't read no "For Sale," it just was a blank. Now when I travel along the expressway and I'm going down the road, which I've been down there blind. Now I got some eyes. I'm seeing some I'm reading like, Kentucky, 40 miles away. When you get there it says "Welcome to Kentucky." I said I passed this place over and over and I just came on in. So it's is so much different today. It's so much different today.
我不会注意到任何那些标志。我所做的只是注意到我的目标，从A到Z。现在，至于阅读像这儿的“待售”这样的标志，我没读到那个。我没读到什么“待售”，它只是空白。现在当我沿高速公路行驶时，我在路上，但我以前是瞎子。现在我有眼睛了。我看到了一些，我读到了，比如，肯塔基州，40英里远。当你到达那里，它说“欢迎来到肯塔基州”。我说我反复经过这个地方，我只是进来了。所以今天太不一样了。今天太不一样了。
We go to make a right turn, but then Charles sees a familiar black and white sign.
我们要向右转，但查尔斯看到了一个熟悉的黑白标志。
Now I see "One Way." That means I can't go there. I would have gone in there when I couldn't read. Yeah, I've been on plenty one ways. And it says "One Way." And the police come down. And I said, "Officer, I'm so sorry. I didn't see the signs."
现在我看到了“单行道”。这意味着我不能往那儿走。我以前识字时会进去的。是啊，我走过很多单行道。上面写着“单行道”。然后警察来了。我说，“警官，我太抱歉了。我没看见标志。”
How much easier does it make getting around the city?
在城市里穿行让你容易多少？
Oh man, it's just that you're alive. I don't know if it's so much easier, it's just that you are alive.
哦天哪，就是你还活着。我不知道是不是容易多少，只是你还活着。
After he quit trucking, Charles went through a really rough period. And then 10 years ago, he sort of pulled himself together. He applied for a civil service job, but he failed the entrance exam so badly that it was finally clear to someone that he couldn't read. He was 45 years old. That's how long it took. Instead of a job, they handed him an address for a literacy program. He still goes there all the time. He tells me he's reading this book for a class there. And when he pulls it out of his briefcase, it's not what I expected.
辞去卡车司机后，查尔斯度过了一段非常艰难的时期。然后10年前，他振作起来了。他申请了一份公务员工作，但他的入学考试考得太糟了，以至于终于有人清楚地知道他不识字。他当时45岁。那花了这么长时间。他们没给他工作，而是递给他一个扫盲班的地址。他现在一直去那儿。他告诉我他正在为班里读这本书。当他把它从公文包里拿出来时，那不是我所期待的。
What book am I reading now? I have to do a report on this simple book, this simple book called Dr. Seuss . "One fish, two fish, red fish, blue fish." If I were to show that to people, they will say, wow. I don't know. They would really try to embarrass you. But at home by myself, I'm happy with just reading this. This is better than reading anything at all. Just a simple book.
我现在在读什么书？我必须为这本简单的书写报告，这本简单的书叫《苏斯博士》。“一条鱼，两条鱼，红鱼，蓝鱼。”如果我把它拿给别人看，他们会说，哇。我不知道。他们真的会试图让你难堪。但在家我自己，读这个我就很开心。这比读什么都好。只是一本简单的书。
It says, "One fish, two fish, red fish, blue fish." And then it has the colors. That's what helps me a whole lot. I look at the pictures. That, no. "The fat one has a yellow hat."
它说，“一条鱼，两条鱼，红鱼，蓝鱼。”然后它有颜色。这就是对我非常有帮助的地方。我看着图画。那个，不。“胖的那条戴着黄帽子。”
Charles told me that his whole life he felt like a fake. And that that was frightening and exhausting. Now he says he feels liberated. And even just being able to read this little bit, or being able to make out his phone bill or follow the instructions on his prescription bottles, makes his life so much easier. Like he'd been traveling in a foreign country all this time and now he's home Everything is different. Now when he gets lost, he says, he can read his way back.
查尔斯告诉我，他的一生感觉自己像个骗子。那很吓人也让人筋疲力尽。现在他说他感到被解放了。甚至仅仅能读懂这一点点，或者能读懂他的电话账单或看懂处方药瓶上的说明，都让他的生活轻松多了。就像他一直以来都在国外旅行，现在他回家了。一切都不同了。他说，现在他迷路了，他能通过阅读找回来。
Jonathan Menjivar in Chicago.
乔纳森·门吉瓦在芝加哥报道。
[MUSIC - "BIG TRUCK DRIVER" BY MYSTIKAL]
[音乐 - MYSTIKAL的《BIG TRUCK DRIVER》]
Act Three, Confessions of a Not-Very-Dangerous Mind. Well sometimes we're backed into a corner by circumstance. Sometimes we're backed into a corner by others conspiring against us. And sometimes we just put ourselves there all on our own. This is that kind of story.
第三幕，一个不太危险的心灵的告白。好吧，有时我们会被环境逼入绝境。有时我们会被他人密谋算计而逼入绝境。有时我们只是自己把自己逼到那儿。这就是那样的故事。
We have in this story a 22 year old taking a lie detector test, a polygraph. It's part of a job interview for a job that he wants more than anything. And the harder he tries to do well, the worse he does. In the story we call him Matt for reasons that will become clear soon enough. Matt is not his real name. His friend Brian Montopolis tells this story. A warning to sensitive listeners that at some point in this story, it mentions the existence of pornography.
我们这个故事里有一个22岁的年轻人正在参加测谎仪测试，多项式测谎。这是一份他极其想要的工作的面试的一部分。他越努力表现得好，他表现得越糟糕。在这个故事中我们称他为马特，原因很快就会明了。马特不是他的真名。他的朋友布莱恩·蒙托波利斯讲述了这个故事。向敏感听众发出警告，在这个故事的某个时刻，提到了色情内容的存在。
In high school, Matt wasn't one of those perfect kids who never made a resume-tarnishing wrong move. For one thing, he was a pothead, a big one. And it wasn't just pot he was into. He tried mushrooms, acid, Ritalin, even air fresheners. Pretty much anything he could get his hands on. But in his freshman year of college, everything changed. He decided what he wanted to do with his life, intelligence work. And he quit the drugs cold turkey. He studied international security, and picked up a language that would help him get a job.
高中时，马特不是那种从没做出过损害简历的错误举动的完美孩子之一。一方面，他是个瘾君子，瘾很大。他不只是沉迷于大麻。他尝试过迷幻蘑菇、迷幻药、利他林，甚至空气清新剂。基本上是他能弄到的任何东西。但在大学一年级，一切都变了。他决定了他想在生活中做什么，情报工作。他果断戒掉了毒品。他学习国际安全，并掌握了一门有助于找到工作的语言。
I actually flipped a coin between Chinese and Arabic knowing that those two languages were both in high demand for the intelligence community. And it came up Chinese. This was before 9/11 so I've been kicking myself ever since.
我实际上在中文和阿拉伯语之间掷硬币决定，因为我知道这两门语言都是情报界的高需求语言。硬币显示中文。那是9/11事件之前，所以我从那以后一直很后悔。
He ended up at one of the best graduate programs in the country for foreign relations. And the hard work paid off. He was offered a job as an intelligence analyst at the National Security Agency. Now all that stood between him and his dream job was a background check and a grueling three day battery of tests. The first day was an IQ test. The second, a psychiatric evaluation. And the third was a polygraph, a lie detector test.
他最终进入了全国最好的研究生课程之一，学习外交关系。努力得到了回报。他获得了国家安全局（NSA）情报分析员的工作。现在，挡在他和他的梦想工作之间的只是一项背景调查和为期三天的艰苦测试。第一天是智商测试。第二天是精神评估。第三天是多项式测谎，即测谎测试。
The first two days went really well. He felt great. But the night before the polygraph, he started getting anxious. He'd heard horror stories about what it'd be like. And he's an anxious guy to begin with. And he lay in bed that night worrying about any possible lies that might accidentally blow it for him, taking the questions apart and putting them back together. And over-thinking everything. For instance--
前两天进行得非常好。他感觉很棒。但在测谎前夜，他开始焦虑起来。他听说过如果测试会是什么样子的恐怖故事。而且他本身就是一个焦虑的人。那天晚上他躺在床上担心任何可能意外让他搞砸的谎言，把问题拆解开再拼回去。而且把一切都过度思考了。例如——
One of the questions that came up while I was talking to a psychiatrist was "Have you ever looked at child pornography?" And right away I said no without even thinking about it because I've never looked at child pornography. And I basically started obsessing about that question, thinking OK, first of all full disclosure. I'm gay. I'm a 21, 22 year old guy. I have looked at pornography on the internet. Like anyone who's looked at anything on the internet, there is the possibility that I've seen something illegal that I thought was legal.
当我和精神科医生交谈时，出现的一个问题是“你曾经看过儿童色情作品吗？”我立刻回答没有，甚至都没考虑，因为我从来没看过儿童色情作品。我基本上开始纠结那个问题，心想好吧，首先坦白。我是同性恋。我是21、22岁的男青年。我在互联网上看过色情作品。就像任何在互联网上看过东西的人一样，有可能我见过一些违法的但我以为是合法的。
But I got nervous because I was thinking, am I now getting myself so stressed out about even the possibility of having accidentally seen child pornography-- someone who was 17 and a half instead of 19-- that I'm now going to fail the test. The polygraph, it doesn't just register lies. It's a test-- a measurement of your stress level.
但我紧张是因为我在想，我是不是现在把自己搞得太紧张了，甚至对仅仅是意外看过儿童色情作品的可能性——某个人是17岁半而不是19岁——以至于我现在要没通过测试。测谎仪，它不只是记录谎言。它是一个测试——是你压力水平的测量。
He got pretty worked up, and not just about this.
他变得非常激动，不仅是因为这个。
But basically here's a conundrum that a person like myself would find themselves going into. And I'm sure other people would have less of a problem because they're less neurotic than I am. But you know this test is a measurement of stress. And yet what is it that even a totally innocent, average person would be incredibly stressed out about going into this test? Failing the test. So yeah, I was nervous. And to be honest, what I was most worried about going in was the whole drug thing.
但基本上这就是像我这样的人会发现自己陷入的难题。而且我相信其他人受到的困扰会更少，因为他们不像我那么神经质。但你知道这个测试是对压力的测量。然而，即使是一个完全无辜的普通人，在进入这个测试时，会因为什么而感到不可思议的压力呢？没通过测试。所以是的，我很紧张。说实话，我进去时最担心的是整个毒品问题。
But their whole thing is if you disclose everything you've done, then you're fine, right? I mean if you say, yeah when I was in high school I smoked a lot of pot. Then that what you're supposed to do.
但他们的逻辑是，如果你披露了你做过的一切，那么就没事了，对吧？我的意思是，如果你说，是的，我在高中时吸了很多大麻。那么这就是你应该做的。
That's one side of it. I mean I've heard that too, that it's like, well it's not so much what you've done. It's whether you've lied or not. Because what they're really worried about is blackmail and extortion and other countries turning you by threatening to reveal your secrets.
那是它的一面。我的意思是，我也听说过，它不那么在于你做了什么。而是在于你是否撒谎。因为他们真正担心的是勒索和敲诈，以及其他国家通过威胁揭露你的秘密来策反你。
I mean on the other hand, if you have murdered three people but you go ahead and tell them in the pre-polygraph interview, it's not like they're going to be, oh well thanks for the candor. When can you start?
我的意思是，另一方面，如果你杀了三个人但你在测谎前采访中告诉了他们，他们不会说，噢好吧，谢谢你的坦诚。你什么时候能开始上班？
When Matt showed up at the NSA building in Maryland for his test, he was taken to a tiny room with a table and two chairs. And he met his interrogator, an African American woman in her 40's. She was very nice and seemed to be going out of her way to make him feel more comfortable. The first part of the session was pretty casual. Matt wasn't even hooked up to the machine. The idea was, if he'd ever done anything wrong in his life, this was the time to confess it.
当马特出现在马里兰州的NSA大楼参加他的测试时，他被带到一个带有桌子和两把椅子的狭小房间。他见到了他的审讯者，一位40多岁的非裔美国女性。她非常友好，似乎竭尽全力让他感觉更舒服。会议的第一部分相当随意。马特甚至还没接上机器。想法是，如果他一生中做过任何错事，现在就是坦白的时候。
You know, and this is the part of the test that people have this running joke like, make sure you admit that you in kindergarten smashed little Timmy's bees wax sculpture. Basically me having the opportunity to expunge every guilty secret I could possibly have. Even at one point, she's like, OK, what crimes have you committed? And I was like, well I'm gay. And she's like, uhh. And I was like that's illegal in some states.
你知道，这是人们开玩笑说的那部分测试，比如，确保你承认你在幼儿园砸了小蒂米的蜂蜡雕塑。基本上我有机会消除我可能拥有的每一个罪恶秘密。甚至有一次，她说，好吧，你犯过什么罪？我说，好吧，我是同性恋。她说，呃。我说那在某些州是非法的。
So obviously I was going out of my way to tell them everything I could. I mean we spent an hour and a half on drugs alone where I was trying to even think of specific dates, which was sort of absurd. I mean if you smoked pot three times a day for your entire senior year of high school, what's the point giving dates?
所以显然我竭尽全力告诉他们我能告诉的一切。我的意思是，我们光是在毒品上就花了一个半小时，我当时甚至试图想到具体日期，这有点荒谬。我的意思是，如果你在整个高中最后一年每天吸三次大麻，给出日期有什么意义？
After a couple hours like this, Matt was finally hooked up to the lie detector. And that's when things started going downhill. The questions, mostly about whether he'd been hiding anything from her in the pre-polygraph interview, were straightforward enough. But Matt could tell from the start that it wasn't going well.
像这样进行了几个小时后，马特终于接上了测谎仪。也就是在那时，事情开始走下坡路。这些问题，大多关于他在测谎前采访中是否对她隐瞒了什么，都够直截了当的。但马特从一开始就能看出事情进展得不顺利。
There were a lot of problems with how I was I guess sitting in the chair or breathing. And she kept stopping the test to give me new instructions that actually made be much more anxious because they seemed to be very contradictory. She would tell me that I was breathing too hard or something, right? And then three minutes later, she would stop the test again and say, Matt, stop trying to control your breathing.
关于我坐在椅子上或呼吸的方式，我猜有很多问题。她不断停止测试给我新的指令，这实际上让我更加焦虑，因为它们似乎非常矛盾。她会告诉我我呼吸太重之类，对吧？然后三分钟后，她又会停止测试说，马特，别试图控制你的呼吸。
Were you trying to control your breathing?
你在试图控制呼吸吗？
I think I was because I was trying to make sure I wasn't breathing too hard. So that was I guess starting to make me feel like there was a problem. And then finally, she just turned the machine off and said, "You're failing. You are failing this test." And I said, well which question? Immediately thinking the drugs question has totally screwed me over.
我想我是在，因为我试图确保自己没呼吸太重。所以我猜这开始让我觉得有问题了。然后最后，她只是把机器关掉说，“你没通过。你没通过这个测试。”我说，好吧，哪个问题？立刻心想毒品问题完全搞砸了我。
And she says well "I'm really getting a bad physiological response on every question." And I'm thinking, every question? And I even said to her, "Does that include the one about me having ever tried to overthrow the US government?" I mean, I'm pretty sure I'd remember. And she was like, yeah, every question.
她说好吧“我在每一个问题上都得到了很糟糕的生理反应。”我在想，每一个问题？我甚至对她说，“这包括我曾经试图推翻美国政府的那个问题吗？”我的意思是，我很确定我会记得。她说，是的，每一个问题。
The machine is off at this point. And it never got turned back on. And I guess the first thing that we started talking about was the drug question because I guess in my mind, I just assumed this must really be the problem. And that's when she was portraying herself as wanting to help me give up some sinister secret. Like this test will all be over once you tell me what it is you're keeping to yourself.
机器此时已关闭。它再也没被打开过。我猜我们开始谈论的第一件事是毒品问题，因为我猜在我脑海里，我只是假设这肯定真的是问题所在。也就是在那时，她表现得想要帮助我放弃一些险恶的秘密。比如一旦你告诉我你对自己隐藏的是什么，这个测试就会结束。
But at this point, you had nothing to tell her?
但在此时，你没什么可告诉她的？
I didn't think that I had anything to tell her. But again, being told that I'm failing the test and that I have something that I still have to tell her, I'm thinking to myself, my god, I'm so screwed. It could be anything. It could be little Timmy's bees wax sculpture. It could be something that I'm not even-- it's not even on my conscious level that I can tell her.
我没想过我有什么可告诉她的。但同样，被告知我没通过测试，而且我还有东西必须告诉她，我在心里对自己说，天哪，我太惨了。可能是任何事情。可能是小蒂米的蜂蜡雕塑。可能是连我——甚至不在我的意识水平，我无法告诉她的事情。
And I'm thinking to myself, as she's going after me more more, OK, obviously she's not going to take no for an answer. I have got to pass this test. I have to get this job. I need to say something to placate her, which I guess was probably the beginning of me really going down that slippery slope of irrationality. Where I'm doing something that is really, really stupid that I'm somehow starting to convince myself is the strategic thing to do the time.
我在心里对自己说，当她越来越紧逼我时，好吧，显然她不会接受否定的答案。我必须通过这个测试。我必须得到这份工作。我需要说点什么来抚慰她，我猜这可能是我真正走向非理性那条滑坡的开始。在那里，我正在做一些真的、真的很愚蠢的事情，但我以某种方式开始说服自己，这是当时要做的战略性事情。
And so, I reached deep inside myself like she wanted me to. And I basically said, oh, you know what it might be? Maybe I was still hung up about the whole child porn thing still. I don't want to say she had a gotcha look on her face, but she definitely did the whole, leaning forward and, well now I'm very interested in what you have to say.
所以，我像她要求的那样深入内心。我基本上说，噢，你知道那可能是什么吗？也许我仍然纠结于整个儿童色情的事情。我不想说她脸上露出了“抓住你了”的表情，但她肯定做了那整套，身体前倾，“好吧，现在我对你要说的很感兴趣。”
And then she said, "Well what do you mean by that?" And I'm like, well maybe I'm still worried that I've seen it unknowingly or unwittingly. And maybe it really bothers me, the idea that I've seen someone even who was a little but underage like 16 or 17. And her mantra for the next hour and a half was, "Look, things are black or white. You either did it or you didn't do it. Stop telling you don't know."
然后她说，“好吧，你这话是什么意思？”我说，好吧，也许我仍然担心我是在不知情或无意中看了它。也许这个想法困扰着我，我见过即使是有点未成年的人，比如16或17岁。她在接下来的一个半小时里的口头禅是，“看，事情是黑白的。你要么做了要么没做。别再说你不知道了。”
Did she start getting really aggressive with you at that point?
在那时，她开始对你变得非常有攻击性了吗？
She was getting so aggressive but-- I mean at one point she slammed one of her fists into her palm and said, "I don't have time for this! We're at war!"
她变得非常有攻击性，但是——我的意思是，有一次她用力握拳砸向掌心说，“我没时间在这儿耗！我们在打仗！”
Wait, wait.
等等，等等。
War? I mean obviously we have been here for four and a half hours now. How can I take what is obviously becoming the worst case scenario for this polygraph and come out on top? And apparently, my conclusion was to go from saying, "Well I just don't know. I don't know what I've done." To saying, "OK, I guess I may have looked at some child porn at some point in my life."
打仗？我的意思是显然我们在这里已经待了四个半小时了。我怎么能把这显然正在变成这个测谎仪的最坏情况带到最后并胜出呢？显然，我的结论是从说，“好吧我只是不知道。我不知道我做了什么。”到说，“好吧，我猜我在生命中的某个时候可能看过一些儿童色情作品。”
So you gave her an absolute, "Yes, I've looked at child porn."
所以你给了她一个绝对的，“是的，我看过儿童色情作品。”
Yes, she got me to eventually say that yes, I've looked at child porn. We really started entering The Twilight Zone in terms of how I was rationalizing what I said to her. And it was at this point when I really began entirely making things up. So she's like, how many images? And I said-- in my mind I'm like, OK, just for my own sense of self-esteem, I'm going to give an answer that makes some sort of sense. So I'm going to say some number that I think maybe represents the highest possible percentage of images that I've seen on the internet that could have possibly been someone who was under 18.
是的，她最终让我说了是的，我看过儿童色情作品。我们就如何合理化我对她所说的话，真正开始进入《阴阳魔界》。正是在这一点上，我真正开始完全胡编乱造。所以她问，有多少图片？我说——在我的脑海里我心想，好吧，为了我自己的自尊心，我要给一个有意义的答案。所以我要说一个数字，我认为也许代表了我在互联网上看到的、可能是18岁以下的人的图片的最大百分比。
And so I say 10. And she immediately responds with, "Now listen to me. If it's just one more than 10. If it's 11, then that means you're still lying to me. So you better come up with a number that absolutely includes the maximum number of images that you've seen." And I'm thinking to myself, well what should I say? 2,000? 12? What do I say? So I think I came up with 50.
所以我说了10。她立刻回应说，“现在听着。如果只是比10多一个。如果是11，那就意味着你还在对我撒谎。所以你最好给出一个绝对包含了你看到的图片最大数量的数字。”我在想，好吧，我该说什么？2000？12？我说什么？所以我猜我说了50。
So you said to this woman, "I have looked at exactly 50 images of child pornography in my lifetime."
所以你对这个女人说，“我在一生中看过正好50张儿童色情图片。”
I think I said I've looked at no more than 50.
我想我说了我没看过超过50张。
You know the funny thing about this whole thing is growing up, I had looked at almost no pornography in my entire life. I had straight friends. I mean most of friends were straight guys. You live with them in the dorm. They all were downloading porn off the internet all the time. And I was feigning interest. And once I came out of the closet, I immediately ended up in a monogamous relationship with someone who I'm still dating today. And I've actually, more so than almost anyone else I know my age, I mean friends of mine, I'm not interested in porn, adult or otherwise.
你知道整件事有趣的地方在于成长过程中，我一生中几乎没看过色情作品。我有异性恋朋友。我的意思是大多数朋友都是异性恋。你和他们住在宿舍里。他们都在不停地从网上下载色情作品。而我是在假装感兴趣。一旦我出柜，我就立即进入了一段单配偶关系，和我现在还在约会的那个人在一起。事实上，比起我认识的同龄人，我的意思是我的朋友，我对色情作品一点都不感兴趣，无论成人的还是其他的。
So for the record, I'm an aficionado nor connoisseur of kiddie porn. So it was totally arbitrary, totally random. And we're joking about it now. But at the time, I'm shaking like a leaf. I feel like I might have a nervous breakdown. It's like blubbering in my seat. And I was like, oh you know could maybe just jot it down that I'd like to have a second test? And she's un-hooking me. And she's like, "Yeah sure, whatever. I'll talk to them."
所以为了记录，我既不是儿童色情作品的爱好者也不是鉴赏家。所以那是完全随意的，完全随机的。我们现在拿它开玩笑。但在当时，我抖得像一片叶子。我觉得我可能要神经崩溃了。这就像在座位上号啕大哭。我说，噢你知道能不能把它记下来，我想要第二次测试？她正在把我解下来。她说，“是啊当然，随便。我会和他们谈谈。”
It'll come as no surprise that Matt didn't get the job. Instead, he got a letter from the NSA saying that his application had been discontinued on the basis of his quote "involvement with child pornography." Getting a rejection letter is one thing, but getting a rejection letter from the United States government saying they know you're into kiddie porn is quite another.
马特没得到这份工作，这并不奇怪。相反，他收到一封来自NSA的信，说他的申请被中止，理由是他“涉及儿童色情作品”。收到一封拒绝信是一回事，但收到美国政府发来的拒绝信说他们知道你沉迷于儿童色情又是另一回事。
Child pornography is a felony. Matt was scared. He hired a lawyer, who told him he wasn't alone, that other people taking polygraphs have admitted to all sorts of things they'd never done. The lawyer arranged for Matt to take new polygraph test. And he passed with flying colors. But the NSA wouldn't change its decision or clear his name. And Matt was haunted by the fact that he'd falsely confessed to an act that repulsed him.
儿童色情是一项重罪。马特很害怕。他聘请了一位律师，律师告诉他他并不孤单，其他人参加测谎仪测试时也承认了各种他们从未做过的事情。律师安排马特参加了新的测谎测试。他以优异的成绩通过了。但NSA不会改变他们的决定或洗清他的名声。而马特一直被这样一个事实所困扰：他虚假地承认了一个让他感到厌恶的行为。
It's a pretty awful thing to know that people out there think that you've done this kind of thing. And maybe this sounds weird, but for several months afterwards, whenever I was standing on a subway platform or something, and there was somebody there with their little kids, I felt kind of dirty. I felt like, you know what, there's someone out there who thinks that I want to see pictures of these kids naked.
知道外面的人认为你做过那种事，这是一件非常糟糕的事情。也许这听起来很奇怪，但在此后的几个月里，每当我站在地铁站台或什么地方，如果有带着小孩的人在那里，我就感到有点肮脏。我觉得，你知道吗，外面有人认为我想看这些孩子的裸照。
Matt was still in grad school when all this happened. And it was hard to drag himself to class every day knowing he was preparing himself for jobs he probably could never have. He gave an intelligence career one last shot and applied for a job at the CIA. But not long after he told them about his NSA interview, they dropped his from the process.
这一切发生时马特还在读研究生。每天拖着自己去上课很困难，因为他知道他正在为他可能永远无法获得的工作做准备。他最后尝试了一次情报职业，申请了CIA的工作。但在他告诉他们关于他的NSA面试后不久，他们就让他退出了过程。
I mean in my mind, without sounding too dramatic, it was basically the end of me working in the career that I wanted to work in.
我的意思是在我心里，没有听起来太夸张，这基本上是我工作的结束，那个我想要从事的职业。
Of course there's a reason for that. Matt cracked. They asked him some questions, and he implicated himself in a crime he never committed. And maybe that's not the sort of person who should be given our nation's security secrets.
当然，这有一个原因。马特崩溃了。他们问了他一些问题，他把自己牵扯进了一项他从未犯过的罪行。也许那不是应该被授予我们国家安全秘密的人。
Do you think that your performance in the interrogation speaks to how well you would have done your job?
你认为你在审讯中的表现说明了你能把工作做得多好吗？
No. Well I mean, if you want me to be totally honest, if I was going to say-- and this could be true-- if my performance in the interview said anything negative about my ability to do the job, maybe it said I was too immature. In the sense that I was the neurotic, overly introspective kid who gave up all this information in the first place when I didn't need to. But I also think there's something wrong with a system that decides that I committed a felony that I didn't commit and keeps me from ever being able to do the job, but it allows in Aldrich Ames, who once they found out that he was a Soviet spy, they got a warrant for his house and they found a statue of Lenin in his back yard. I mean how come they missed that when they got me?
不。好吧，我的意思是，如果你想让我完全诚实，如果要说——这可能是真的——如果我在采访中的表现对我的工作能力说明了什么负面情况，也许它说明了我太不成熟了。在我最初不需要的时候，我就交出了所有这些信息，那个神经质、过度内省的孩子。但我还认为，一个决定我犯了没犯过的重罪并让我永远无法从事这份工作的系统有问题，但它却允许阿尔德里奇·艾姆斯进去，一旦他们发现他是苏联间谍，他们就对他的家发出了搜查令，他们在他的后院发现了列宁的雕像。我的意思是，当他们抓住我时，他们怎么会错过那个？
He's given up intelligence work for now and moved across the country to begin a new career. I'd tell you where he went and what he's doing, but he doesn't want me to. These days, Matt would rather say too little than too much. And keep some things to himself. Brian Montopolis.
他目前已经放弃了情报工作，搬到了全国另一端开始新的职业生涯。我会告诉你他去了哪里他在做什么，但他不想让我说。这些天，马特宁愿说得太少也不愿说得太多。并把一些事情放在心里。布莱恩·蒙托波利斯。
Well our program is produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Kevin Clark. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our shows for absolutely free. Or buy CDs of them. And you know you can download today's program and our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
好吧，我们的节目今天由萨拉·柯尼格和我本人制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、黛安·库克、温迪·多尔、简·费尔特斯和丽莎·波拉克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和凯文·克拉克提供了制作帮助。我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费地听我们的节目。或者购买它们的CD。你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载今天的节目和我们的档案。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who sat me down at the mixing console in our radio studio years ago and explained to me how he runs the controls.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，多年前他让我坐在我们广播工作室的混音控制台前，并向我解释了他如何运行这些控制。
The gauges or whatever they're saying. You really, really didn't pay that much attention. They were just there. You just knew that you had to work to make a living. You know what I'm saying?
仪表，或者它们在说什么。你真的，真的没有太注意。它们只是在那里。你只知道你必须工作来养家糊口。你懂我的意思吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》的更多故事。
You know what I mean? You aren't going to let any gauges stop $400 or $500 coming in your home for a week.
你知道我的意思吗？你不会让任何仪表挡住你每周挣回家的400或500美元。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。